I apparently am going through inflammation of past musculoskeletal injuries as a side-effective
radiation treatment for stage 4 lung tumor. The last of 30, I assume, radiation treatments,
you see, targeted low-level dose was June 10th. Radiation was accompanied by a chemo during the
30 days as maintenance following the end of radiation treatment. The good news is the tumor is
greatly degraded. The bad news is that the area where it broke three ribheads happened two years ago
and a jointed sternum, which was not injured, recently became inflamed that are sensitive to the
touch from this as a sensitive to the touch. Pain from this has referred to back muscles,
including the erector muscles, and according to my deep tissue massage therapist question,
could my right cancer program be contributed to the inflammation? I see there is an inflammation
program in the right list. Should I be doing that? So can your cancer program be contributing to
the inflammation? No. Cancer program is going to be targeting the cancer. Could it cause some
inflammation around it? If there's cancer that exists there, there could be some inflammation
around the cancer that would be an immune reaction around the cancer, but it wouldn't cause musculoskeletal
inflammation at all. It's not uncommon that radiation lingers. That's the problem with
your radiation therapy, although it could kill cancer, it couldn't linger in your system or
emperor. So pulling that radiation out at this point, you see your best interest, I would highly
recommend using the radiallgen, a wheelpad, but our store or the radiation of a wheelpad for both of
them on the store. They're just homeopathic drops that could target your body to help you detoxify
that. I highly recommend that. Is there an inflammation program in the right that you could be using?
Yes, you could be using that as well. However, I would say that while frequencies can help with
radiation, you have to use more metabolic approach to inflammation. So using homeopathy,
using anti-inflammatory flavonoids, like a plant called inflammatory tone or paparrest from
biotics, either one of those have a lot of anti-inflammatory flavonoids. The inflammatory
clearing enzyme is probably tests usually stronger than paparrest on most people. Everything's
a little bit different, but those have flavonoids that curcumin the bus wellie and the sticky dental,
the resveratrol, the rosemary, the corset and those are the things that are going to help decrease
inflammation. So I would be taking fairly high doses of that. There really isn't an upper limit.
You can't really overdose on those things. But you have to spread them out through the day. They
all are water soluble. They have a half-life that's fairly short of the room, which is half-life
of resveratrol is only like five minutes. It's the shortest half-life of getting nutrient that
exists. So you have to be spreading that out through the day. That's your best advantage to that.
Definitely, when you do radiation to kill cancer cells, you are weakening other cells as well.
So if you had musculoskeletal injury, an old fracture, an old muscle injury, tendon
ligamentus injury, they're going to be weakened and you're going to be more susceptible to injury.
Certainly ribbed carcostal cartilage issues are very common because your ribs are always moving
every grain through tank. Costal cartilage injuries take a long time to heal.
So it sounds like you're doing deep tissue massage. Other things may be beneficial as well.
You can cold, hot, cold, max, things like that will maybe help both. Different therapies may be helpful.
Even laser treatment, even depends on where it is. Certainly on your back, if you use electrical
Stim, PE of app, can be helpful as well.